I think I look fantastic. I look like Legolas. Here we go. That's not how you pronounce that. Legolas? Legolas? Whatever. Oh no. Oh no. Oh no. That is not good. What were you thinking? And it's like shaved on the side and oh no. Oh no, Connor. Do they really let you have hair like that and be an actuary welcome to adsp the podcast episode 11 recorded on jan 24th 2021. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce we talk about what belongs in a standard library and more.
我认为我看起来棒极了。我看起来像莱戈拉斯。我们开始吧。这不是那样发音的。莱戈拉斯？莱戈拉斯？随便啦。哦，不。哦，不。哦，不。那可真不好。你在想什么呢？而且它的侧面还剃了，哦，不。哦，不，康纳。他们真的允许你留那种发头还能当精算师吗？欢迎来到 adsp 播客第 11 期，录制于 2021 年 1 月 24 日。我的名字是康纳，今天与我的共同主持布莱斯一起，我们讨论标准库中应包含什么以及更多内容。
So uh I got an idea. You got an idea? Okay. Yeah I think we should talk about what belongs in the standard library. Okay. Is this C++ specific or is this uh i think it is okay because well i i guess it's kind of a comparison of language standard libraries is really a part of this because um i think that the the the the there are a lot of people trying to put things in the C++ standard library. And I think a lot of the things that people wish to see in the C++ standard library that aren't suitable for the C++ standard library, folks want to see those things because they expect them to be there in other languages' standard libraries. And they perhaps don't understand the difference between the C++ standard library and the standard library of other languages. So just because two languages both say that they have a standard library or foundational libraries doesn't mean that
所以，嗯，我有个主意。你有个主意？好吧。对，我认为我们应该聊聊标准库里应该包含什么。好吧。这是 C++ 专有的，还是，嗯，我觉得可以，因为，嗯，我想这有点像语言标准库的比较，这确实是其中的一部分，因为，嗯，我觉得，有很多很多人试图把东西塞进 C++ 标准库里。而且我认为人们希望在 C++ 标准库中看到但并不适合 C++ 标准库的许多东西，大家之所以想看到它们，是因为他们期望其他语言的标准库里有这些东西。他们可能不理解 C++ 标准库与其他语言标准库的区别。因此，仅仅因为两种语言都说它们有标准库或基础库，并不意味着
they have the same, that doesn't mean that they're the same thing, or that they have the same requirements, or that they have the same challenges. And I think first we have to start by defining what a standard library is for C++ or for any language. And I think that standard libraries have one key property, and it's the one key property that everybody's interested in. And that property is the standard libraries are the set of libraries
它们是相同的，这并不意味着它们是同一个东西，或者它们具有相同的要求，或者它们面临相同的挑战。我认为首先我们必须从定义标准库对 C++ 或任何语言的作用开始。而且我认为标准库有一个关键属性，这也是每个人都感兴趣的一个关键属性。这个属性就是，标准库是在你安装该语言时就可用、无需添加任何额外软件包的一组库。
that are available when you install the language without adding any extra packages. So when you just install the base Python packages, which libraries do you get without adding other Python libraries? When you install a C++ compiler, what libraries do you have without adding other libraries? When you install Java, what class libraries do you have without going and adding other ones? And the reason why this property is key is because things that are in that set of standard libraries that are automatically installed with the language or compiler, they get implicit distribution. awesome package and you're like, great, I want to use it, you're more likely to use that package if you don't have to install it, if you just happen to have it installed
所以当你只安装基本的 Python 软件包时，在不添加其他 Python 软件包的情况下，你会得到哪些库？当你安装 C++ 编译器时，在不添加其他库的情况下，你拥有哪些库？当你安装 Java 时，在不添加其他类库的情况下，你拥有哪些类库？这个属性之所以关键，是因为那些属于该标准库集合中的东西会自动随语言或编译器安装，它们能获得隐式分发。超棒的软件包，然后你觉得，太棒了，我想用它，如果你不必安装它，如果你碰巧在系统上安装了它，你更有可能使用该软件包
on your system. And that is the case for the standard library. Whereas if the package is something that you have to install, even if it's in a language where it's very easy to install a third-party package, something like Python or Rust, that is still an extra hurdle. And you might be in a space where you're like, oh, I don't want to add extra dependencies. There's still this extra step that you have to do, and it makes it less likely that people are going to use that
在你的系统上。标准库就是这种情况。而如果某个软件包是你必须安装的，即使在那种安装第三方软件包非常容易的语言中，比如 Python 或 Rust，这仍然是一个额外的障碍。你可能处于这样一种环境中：哦，我不想添加额外的依赖项。你仍然需要做这个额外的步骤，这会降低人们使用该库的可能性
library. And so that's what I think really makes a standard library is that it is a component that comes with the language by default. Does that make sense? Yes, that made sense. And to summarize, so the key property of a standard library is just that it comes with the language that's the key property yeah um exactly and and so you know that explains why there is a desire to have rich standard libraries because um you know if you think that there's something that's really important for your programmers to have access to um or that's going to make it, you know, it's going to make your language better. And like, why wouldn't you want it to just be there by default? Like, it's the easiest option if all you care about is getting your library into the hands of programmers. The easiest option by far is just to have everybody implicitly install it. It's the easiest route to get
库。所以这就是我认为真正造就标准库的原因，即它是一个默认随语言附带的组件。这讲得通吗？是的，这讲得通。总而言之，标准库的关键属性就是它随语言附带，这就是关键属性，对吧？嗯，完全正确，所以你知道，这就解释了为什么人们渴望拥有丰富的标准库，因为，嗯，你知道，如果你认为有些东西对你的程序员来说非常重要，必须能够访问，嗯，或者这会使它，你知道，会让你的语言变得更好。而且，为什么不希望它默认就存在呢？如果你只关心如何将你的库交到程序员手中，这是最简单的选择。到目前为止，最简单的选择就是让每个人都隐式安装它。这是获得采用的最简单途径
adoption. But, you know, there is a cost. So, you know, the first cost is, of course, that the larger that core set of libraries is, the larger your actual, you know, core package is. One of the key principles of C++ is you don't pay for what you don't use. And so everything that you add to that standard library makes the size of that core package, larger and larger. But I think more importantly, perhaps, there is a maintenance cost. I think most languages try to have a set of standard libraries that have a coherent design to them, that it's not a collection of libraries, but it is one coherent library where all of the APIs sort of fall the same style. I will note what I think is an important exception to this, which is the Python standard libraries. If you look at the set of like core Python libraries, there is actually a fairly notable divergence in the
。但是，你知道，这是有代价的。所以，你知道，第一个代价当然是，核心库的集合越大，你实际的核心软件包也就越大。C++ 的核心原则之一是你不用为你未使用的东西付费。因此，你添加到该标准库中的每一样东西都会使该核心软件包的体积越来越大。但我认为更重要的是，可能存在维护成本。我认为大多数语言都试图拥有一组设计连贯的标准库，它不是一堆库的集合，而是一个连贯的库，其中所有的 API 基本上都遵循相同的风格。我要指出我认为其中一个重要的例外，那就是 Python 标准库。如果你看一下核心 Python 库的集合，你会发现其中一些库组件在 API 风格甚至命名约定上实际上存在相当明显的差异。我相信这是因为 Python 的工作方式是，其中许多库最初是作为第三方库开始的，然后它们被采用并纳入了核心集合中。你知道这准确吗？我无法证实或否认这一点。而且我甚至都不知道。凭我的第一印象，我知道有一个内置函数页面。但是 Python 的——它们叫核心还是标准？我不知道它们叫什么，不过
API style and even the naming conventions among some of those library components. And I believe that's because the way that it works in Python is that a number of those libraries started off as third-party libraries and then they were adopted into sort of the core set. Do you know if that's accurate? I cannot confirm or deny that. And I actually don't even know. Off the top of my head, I know that there's a built-in functions page. But what are the Python – are they called core or standard? I don't know what they're called but
我在想，比如，嗯，Python 标准库，嗯，对，对，就像我脑海里浮现的东西是，嗯，比如用于解析参数的 Python 库，因为我想在我的编写糟糕的 Python 代码的历史中，我觉得，我觉得以前有过两个不同的参数解析库。我知道其中一个现在已经不鼓励使用了，那可能是我习惯使用的那个。然后我觉得较新的一的一个叫 arg parse。
i'm thinking like the um uh the python standard library uh yeah yeah like something the thing the one that comes to mind to me is um like the python libraries for parsing arguments um because i think i've in in my history of writing bad Python code, I think there've, I think I, I think there are two different argument parsing libraries that have been around historically. I know one of them is like discouraged from being used these days, and that's probably the one that I'm used to using. And then I think the newer one's called arg parse.
嗯，但是，是的，这就好比，这就好比是一个例子，比如你从来不需要安装我习惯使用的那个。然后我觉得较新的一的一个叫 argparse。但是，是的，这就是一个例子。你从来不需要为 argparse 安装软件包。它随你的 Python 安装一起提供。但我相信这也是作为一个独立库开始，然后被添加到该标准集中的东西。有人编写了一些第三方库，也许他们把它放在了 GitHub 上，然后最终，Python 社区决定将其作为标准库的一部分。是的，我的猜测是，就像我正在看 Python 文档网站一样，这里支持大量的库。所以我认为，你知道，如果我们有 Python 听众，他们可以在推特上 @ 我们并纠正我们。
Um, but yeah, like that, that, that's an example, like, like you've never had to install the I'm used to using. And then I think the newer one's called argparse. But yeah, that's an example. You've never had to install the package for argparse. That just comes with your Python installation. But I believe that that was something that started off as its own library, and then it got added into that standard set. Somebody wrote some third-party library, and maybe they put it on GitHub, and then it eventually, the Python community decided to adopt it as part of the standard library. Yeah, my guess is just on, like, I'm on the Python docs website, and there is a massive number of libraries that are supported here. So I think, you know, if we have Python listeners, they can tweet at us and correct
但我很确定其中一些正如你所说的那样，它是由潜在的核心开发人员编写的独立库，但也可能不是。然后它变得非常有用，随着时间的推移，它们被折叠到了标准中。是的，具体来说，就像我正在看 iter tools，这可能是我最常用的库之一。还有另一个版本，more iter tools，它基本上就是该库的一个扩展。但那个并不在标准中。
us. But I'm pretty sure some of these is it's exactly what you said, it was a standalone library written by potentially, you know, core core developers, but potentially not. And then it just became so useful, that over time, they were folded into the standard. Yeah, specifically, like I'm looking at iter tools, which is probably like one of the most common libraries that I use. There's another version, more iter tools, which is basically just like an extension of that library. But that one's not in the standard.
你必须去 PyPI 或任何包管理器并用 pip 安装它。是的。所以 Python 标准库的好处之一是它非常丰富。你知道，里面有很多不同的功能，你默认就能得到。不过我认为 Python 标准库的好处之一是它非常丰富。你知道，里面有很多不同的功能，你默认就能得到。但我认为它的一个地方，它的一个弱点是它没有那种与其他语言的标准库相同的接口一致性
You have to go to PyPI or whatever package manager and pip install it. Yeah. And so one of the nice things about the Python standard library is it's very rich. You know, there's a lot of different capabilities in there that you just get by default. But I think one of the nice things about the Python standard library is it's very rich. You know, there's a lot of different capabilities in there that you just get by default. But I think one of the places where it, one of the weaknesses is that it does not have that same interface consistency
，因为在 Python 中，它实际上是一个库的集合。它不是一个连贯的库。它是一个不同库的集合。其中一些不同的库可能具有略微不同的做事方式
as other languages, standard libraries, because the, in Python, really that it's a collection of libraries. It's not one coherent library. It's a collection of different libraries. And some of those different libraries may have slightly different ways of doing things
或略微不同的风格。而且，你知道，如果你看一下像 C++ 这样的语言，它在许多方面与 Python 非常不同，但可以说在库的设计和包管理的故事方面差异最大。即使在 C++ 中，标准库中的几乎所有内容也都是从第三方库开始的。98 年被采纳的 C++ 标准库的最初基础是亚历克斯·斯特帕诺夫（Alex Stepanov）的 STL 库，
or slightly different styles to them. And, you know, if you look at, you know, a language like C++, which is very different from Python in a number of ways, but arguably is most different in the design of the library and in terms of the package management story. Even in C++, pretty much everything that's in the standard library started off as a third-party library. The original basis for the C++ standard library that was adopted in 98 was Alex Stepanov's STL library,
这是一个第三方库。现在，标准委员会在亚历克斯·斯特帕诺夫出现之前就知道他们需要一个标准库。标准库中有些组件并不是取自 STL。我相信 locales 和 IO streams 不是 STL 的一部分。这是一个独立的组件，不一定来自任何现有的第三方库。但像容器和算法等东西，都来自 STL。所以委员会在 98 年制定标准时，他们表示认识到我们需要一个库。他们开始设计其中的一些组件。但后来在某个时候，我不记得是谁了，但有人注意到了亚历克斯的 STL 库。
which was this third-party library. Now, the standards committee, they knew they needed a standard library before Alex Stepanov came around. And there are components of the standard library that weren't taken from the STL. I believe that locales and IO streams were not part of the STL. That was a separate component that did not necessarily come from any pre-existing third-party library. But things like the containers and the algorithms, etc., those all came from the STL. So the committee, back when they were putting together 98, they said they recognized we need a library. And they started designing some of the components to it. But then at some point, I don't remember who, but somebody became aware of Alex's STL library.
他说，你知道吗？这才是标准库应该有的样子。他把它带给了委员会。他说，嘿，看，这是这个。它是新颖的。它是具有突破性的。我认为我们应该发布它。委员会确实在发布 STL 方面冒了很大的风险。
And he was like, you know what? This is what the standard library should be. And he brought it to the committee. And he said, hey, look, here's this. It's novel. It's groundbreaking. And I think that we should ship it. And the committee really took a big risk on shipping the STL.
如果你想了解更多关于这段历史的信息，约翰·卡尔布（John Kalb）做过一些非常棒的演讲，关于 C++ 的总体历史，特别是关于 C++ 历史上的这一时刻。我确信我们会在节目笔记中添加一些指向它们的链接。但对于 C++ 来说，这确实是一个重大的决定，要对这种未经验证的设计冒这个险。然后，如果你看一下 C++ 标准库的下一个重大修订版 C++11，在那段时期，人们开玩笑说那本质上只是将 Boost 标准化。Boost 是一个，你知道的，广受欢迎的第三方
And if you ever want to learn a little bit more about the history of this, John Kalb has given some really great talks about the history of C++ in general, but in particular, talking about this moment in C++'s history. I'm sure we'll add some links to them in the show notes. But this is really a monumentous decision for C++ to take this risk on this sort of unproven design. And then if you look at the next big revision of the C++ standard library, C++11, back during that time, people joked that that was essentially just standardizing Boost. Boost was this, you know, this popular collection of third-party
C++ 库集合，而 C++11 采用了其中的许多库，比如 Boost Atomics 库、Boost concurrent、Boost thread 库。可能还有其他一些我没想到的，但作为一个主要从事并发编程的人，这两个是我想到的。然后到了 C++ 17，我们的下一个重大库发布，我们根据我参与开发的库 Thrust 标准化了并行算法，并根据 Boost 文件系统标准化了文件系统库。而在 C++20 中引入的 ranges 最初是 GitHub 上一个非常受欢迎的库。因此，C++ 一直遵循采用现有第三方库设计的相同模式。我喜欢告诉人们关于什么属于标准库的座右铭之一是，当存在明确需求时，我们对
C++ libraries, and C++11 adopted many of those libraries, like the Boost Atomics library, the Boost concurrent, the Boost thread library. There's probably a number of other ones that I'm not thinking of, but being primarily somebody who does concurrent programming, those are the two that come to mind. And then in C++ 17, our next big library release, we standardized parallel algorithms based on a library I work on, Thrust, and a file system library based on Boost file system. And ranges that came in C++20 started off as a very popular library on GitHub. So C++ has followed the same model of sort of adopting designs from existing third-party libraries. One of the things that the mantra I like to tell people about what belongs in the standard library is we standardize
现有实践进行标准化。所谓标准化现有实践，我的意思是，在可能的情况下，我们不会试图在委员会中自己发明东西。每当有机会审视现实世界中的情况并加以采用时，我们都会尽量这样做。我们知道某事可能已经成熟可以进行标准化的方法之一，是如果我们看到同一个东西在不同的框架中有三四个不同的版本，那么这可能意味着是时候对其进行标准化了。所以在 C++ 中让你的东西得以标准化的最佳方法之一——让你的东西被添加到标准库中的方法之一——就是如果你能在你的论文中列出一个清单，在其中你可以说，这里有五个开源库的链接，它们具有一个名为，无论什么名字的结构，这与本论文中的这个结构是同一回事。如果我能去查看每一个这样的东西，并仔细检查说，嘿，是的，所有这些东西都是同一个东西。
existing practice when there is a clear need. And by standardized existing practice, what I mean is we don't try to invent things ourselves in the committee when possible. Whenever we have the opportunity to look at what's in the wild and to adopt that, we try to do that. And one of the ways that we know that something is maybe ripe for standardization is if we see three or four different versions of basically the same thing in different frameworks, then maybe that means that it's time to standardize it. So one of the best ways to get your thing standardized in C++ to get your thing added to the standard library is if you can make a list in your paper where you can say, here's links to five open source libraries that have a construct called, you know, whatever, that's the same thing as this construct in this paper. And if I can go and look at each one of those things and I can look through and say, hey, yeah, all of these things are the same thing. then that that indicates that yeah this is a design that that is used in the wild by a lot of people and it's even better if you can do this in a way that that demonstrates that there's a
这就表明，是的，这是一种在现实世界中被很多人使用的设计，如果你能以一种证明对互操作性有需求的方式做到这一点，那就更好了——如果所有这五个库都公开了这种类型，但它们并非全部可互操作，并且用户可能希望将其中一种此类东西传递到这每一个库中，好吧，这就构成了一个理由，嘿，是的，这也许应该成为标准库的一部分，成为词汇表的一部分。是的，所以这通常是我们如何在 C++ 中进行标准化的关键所在，这种想法是我们希望审视现有实践并采用现有实践，而不一定自己去发明。但这把我们带到了 C++ 标准库与许多其他语言之间的巨大差异，即 C++ 标准库是一个规范。它不是一个实现。因此，即使我们采用基于某些现有第三方库的东西，我们也不是只拿着那个库随 C++ 编译器一起发布。
need for interoperability like if of all five of those libraries expose this type, but they're not all interoperable and a user might want to pass one of these kinds of things into each one of those libraries, well, then that makes a case for, hey, yeah, maybe this should be a part of the standard library, part of the vocabulary. And yeah, so that is often sort of key to how we standardize in C++, this idea of we want to look at existing practice and we want to adopt existing practice, not necessarily invent on our own. But this gets us to the big difference between the C++ standard library and a lot of other languages, which is the C++ standard library is a specification. It's not an implementation. And so even if we're adopting something that is based upon some existing third-party library, we're not just taking that library and shipping it with C++ compilers.
有三大标准库实现。当我们标准化某些东西时，这三个实现都必须去实现它。近年来，我们开始在不同的库之间有一些共享实现。这一进程得到了加速，因为微软标准库（三大开源之一中唯一不是开源的那一个，也就是微软的那一个）现在开源了。所以现在所有的库都是开源的。GCC 的库使用 GPL 许可证。另外两个使用的是非常相似的许可证，使用的是更宽松的许可证。LLVM 的库当然使用的是 LLVM 许可证。
There are three major standard library implementations. And when we standardize something, all three of those implementations have to go and implement it. And we have in recent years started to have some shared implementation between different libraries. And this has been accelerated by the fact that the Microsoft standard library, which was the one of the three big ones that was not open source, was the Microsoft one. It is now open source. So now all of the libraries are open source. The GCC ones under a GPL license. The other two are under very similar sort of license, are under a more liberal type of license. The LLVM ones under the LLVM license, of course.
这使得在它们之间共享代码变得更容易。因此，看起来在这些标准库之间将有一些共享实现，例如并行算法。我的团队在一些并发原语上做了一些实现工作，它已经向多个标准库做出了贡献。所以我们开始看到它们之间有一些共享实现，但它们仍然是不同的代码库。因此，开门见山地说，如果你想在 C++ 中向标准库添加某些东西，其实现工作量是作为第三方库发布的 3 倍，维护工作量也是 3 倍。因为你需要将它落地到这些主要的标准库代码库中的每一个。
And so this makes it easier to share code between them. And so it looks like there's going to be some shared implementation of, for example, the parallel algorithms between some of these standard libraries. And my team, which has done some implementation work on some concurrency primitives, has made contributions to multiple standard libraries. So we're starting to see there be some shared implementation between them, but there's still different code bases. And so just off the bat, if you want to add something to the standard library in C++, it is 3x the implementation work and 3x the maintenance work of shipping it as a third-party library. Because you need to land it in each one of these major standard library code bases.
另一个挑战是，你知道，标准库，它确实，它的部署规模是其他软件所罕见的。它基本上运行在地球上的每一个设备上。大约有 500 万 C++ 开发者用户，这是一个非常庞大的开发者用户群。它必须几乎在所有类型的硬件上以及针对所有各种不同类型的应用程序运行。因此，它必须担心其他库可能不需要考虑的边缘情况。因为如果我提供一个第三方库来做某事，我可以选择说，我将专注于这组用户。我承认你可能拥有的这个其他用例的有效性，但它现在不是我的优先级。例如，ranges v3 选择了一组非常特定的编译器，它将
And another one of the challenges is, you know, the standard library, it really, it's deployed at a scale which is uncommon for other software. It runs on essentially every device on the planet. There's about 5 million C++ developer users, which is a very large developer user base. And it has to run on pretty much all types of hardware and for all various different types of applications. So it has to worry about corner cases that other libraries may not need to. Because if I'm providing a third-party library to do something, I can choose to say, I'm going to focus on these sets of users. And I recognize the validity of this other use case that you might have, but it's not a priority for me right now. Like for example, ranges v3 selected a very specific set of compilers that it was going to
专注于一组非常特定的平台。而标准库中的 C++ ranges 则没有那种奢侈，因为它们必须部署在部署了 C++ 编译器的任何地方。我们没有选择只说这个库或这个功能将不适用于所有 C++ 用户。所以，拥有这种到处隐式可用的特性，既是一种福气也是一种诅咒。那就是，是的，这意味着每个人都可以直接安装你的——就像每个安装了该语言的人都拥有这个库一样，但这也意味着该库必须适合将要安装该语言的每个人。这是一个非常高的门槛。另一个真正的问题是，标准库维护者不是领域专家。他们不一定是
focus on in a very specific set of platforms. Whereas C++ ranges in the standard library, they don't have that luxury because they have to be deployed everywhere that C++ compilers are deployed. And we don't have the choice of just saying this library or this feature is not going to be available for all C++ users. So it's about the blessing and a curse to have this implicit availability everywhere. That, yes, it means that everybody can just install your, like, everybody who installs the language just has the library, but it also means that the library has to work for everybody that's going to install the language. That's a really high bar to clear. And the other real problem is that the people who are standard library maintainers aren't domain experts. They're not necessarily
实现某种特定类型库的合适人选。他们可能不具备实现，比如说，XML 解析器的正确专业知识。而作为领域专家、XML 解析器实现专家的那些人，又缺乏标准库开发的经验。他们不知道在那种规模下发布 C++ 标准库是什么感觉。因此，实际的工作很难完成，而且同样地，这必须在三个不同的地方进行。所以我认为，把东西放进标准库实际上是非常低效的。你最终不得不支持许多实际上可能不需要你的东西的用户，以及许多你的库实际上可能不需要支持的环境和平台
the right person to implement, you know, some particular type of library. They're not the right, maybe they don't have the right expertise to implement, you know, an XML parser. And the people who are domain experts, who are experts in implementing XML parsers, they don't have the experience with standard library development. They don't know what it's like to have to ship in a C++ standard library at that scale. So it's difficult to do the actual work, which again has to be done in three different places. And so I'd argue that putting things in the standard library is actually very inefficient. You end up having to support a lot of users who may not actually need your thing and a lot of environments and platforms where your library may not actually really need to be supported
因为你可能在那里没有用户，但如果你在标准库中，你仍然必须支持他们。而且实现起来非常低效，因为你必须以标准库期望的方式在所有这些不同的标准库实现中实现它。当然，这还没算上整个问题，你知道，它究竟是如何进入标准的。你必须编写一个实际的规范规范非常擅长稳定性，但它在
because you might not have users there, but you still have to support them if you're in the standard library. And it's very inefficient to implement because you've got to implement it in all of these different standard library implementations in the way that a standard library expects. And of course, that's just leaving out the whole question of, you know, how does it actually get into the standard. You have to write an actual normative specification very good at stability, but it's not so good at
修复错误方面表现不佳。我们在标准库中进行破坏 ABI 的更改和破坏 API 的更改是非常困难的。这并不适合所有第三方库。一些第三方库可能希望发展得更快，也许是因为它们所在的领域是一个活跃研究的领域，每隔几年就会出现新算法，或者有一些需要更改接口的创新。这就是我对标准库本质的洋洋洒洒的痛陈。所以 API 稳定性、ABI 稳定性、三倍的实现工作量、三倍的维护工作量、平台支持。你是不是想建立一个论点，即出于所有这些原因，
fixing its mistakes. It's very hard for us to make ABI breaking changes and API breaking changes in the standard library. And that's not the right fit for all third-party libraries. Some third-party libraries might want to evolve faster maybe because the domain that they're in is a domain where there's active research and where every few years a new algorithm comes out or there's some innovation that requires interface changes. So that's my rant on the nature of standard libraries. So API stability, ABI stability, three times the implementation work, three times the maintenance work, platform support. Are you trying to build an argument that nothing should go, or not nothing, but a very select number of things should be going in the C++ standard library for all of these
什么都不应该进，或者说不是什么都不应该进，但应该只有极少数经过精挑细选的东西进入 C++ 标准库？就像你开始时那样，我想，其中一个关键属性是，你知道，但出于所有这些原因，极少数经过精挑细选的东西应该进入 C++ 标准库。就像你开始时那样，我想，其中一个关键属性是，你知道，它是随语言附带的，人们可以轻松访问它，并且它会被更多地利用。但随后显然有一个巨大的价格标签和所有这些事情。所以我想，关于应该有多少东西，比如，我们是否应该努力，我们是否应该努力减慢我们把东西放进去的速度，因为，你知道，当你经历 98、11、17 和 20 时，你只提到了你，你知道的，诸如 variant、optional 等等的一小部分东西，诸如被添加到标准库中的东西的列表没完没了，而且，你知道，我不想挑出
reasons? Like there, you started, I guess, with sort of the one key property is that, you know, But a very select number of things should be going in the C++ standard library for all of these reasons. Like you started, I guess, with sort of the one key property is that, you know, it's what comes with the language and people have easy access to it and it'll get utilized more. But then there's obviously like a huge price tag and all these things. So I guess is there like what are your thoughts on how much stuff should, like, should we be trying to, should we be trying to decelerate, like, the, the rate that we put things in, like, because, like, while you were going through 98 and 11 and 17 and 20, you only mentioned, like, a fraction of the things that you, like, you know, variant optional, the list goes on and on and on of, like, what's being added to the standard library, and, you know, I don't want to pick
当前处于提案流程中的任何论文。但有许多，你知道的，非常庞大的非平凡库正在被提议。而且，你知道，我确信并非所有这些都会被接受，但我确信其中一些会。是的，你对此有何看法，你知道，我们是否应该尝试寻找一小部分东西并提出这些提案？还是我们应该把所有的精力都投入到像包管理器这样的东西上？所以，我的意思是，我绝对是小型 C++ 标准库的倡导者。而且我确实相信，人们对 C++ 包管理效率的渴望有很多。几年来我一直说，我认为我们在未来 10 年可以为 C++ 做的最重要的事情，就是让在 C++ 项目中使用第三方库变得
out any of the papers that are currently in the proposal process. But there are a number of, you know, non trivial libraries that are quite large that are being proposed. And, you know, I'm sure not all of them will get in, but I'm sure some of them will. Yeah, what are your thoughts on, you know, should we be trying to find a small set of things and propose those? Or should we be trying to put all our energy into like a package manager? So, I mean, I definitely am an advocate for a small C++ standard library. And I do believe that a lot of the desire foriciency of C++ package management. I've said for a few years that I think the single most important thing that we can do for C++ over the next 10 years is make it
简单几个数量级。这意味着包管理，这意味着构建系统，这并不一定意味着在标准上下文中做这两件事中的任何一件。标准委员会实际上只拥有 C++ 程序的文本。处理诸如包管理或构建系统之类的事情有点超出了我们的职责范围，对我们来说做起来也很棘手。但我认为，如果 C++ 拥有像 Rust 或 Python 那样丰富的包管理系统，我不认为会有那么大的需求
orders of magnitude easier to use third-party libraries in C++ projects. And that means package management, that means build systems, and that doesn't necessarily mean doing either of those things within the context of the standard. The standard committee really only owns the text of C++ programs. And dealing with things like package management or build systems is a little bit outside of our mandate and would also be tricky for us to do. But I think that if C++ had as rich a package management system as, say, Rust or Python, I don't think there would be as much demand
把东西放进标准库。不过，标准库不能替代包管理。我认为这是关键所在，仅仅为了让它们被广泛使用而将东西放入 C++ 标准库并不是一个充分的理由，因为实现的成本很高，因为把东西放进标准库效率非常低，因为一旦我们把东西放进标准库，以后很难修复它们。所有这些事情，我认为，
to put things in the standard library. The standard library though is not a substitute for package management. I think that's the key thing is that it is not a sufficient justification to put things in the C++ standard library simply so that they're widely available to people because of the high costs to implement, because it's very inefficient to put things in the standard library, because once we put things into the standard library, it's very hard to fix them later. All of those things, I think,
促使我们倾向于拥有一个更小的标准库，因为那是低风险的。把东西放进标准库是高风险的。我们必须非常确定我们把它们弄对了。至于我认为什么属于标准库，我认为进入标准库的东西需要满足这三个标准之一。这就是我在“当存在明确需求时我们对现有实践进行标准化”这一座右铭中所指的明确需求。是的，我正要问这个，因为，是的，明确需求，取决于你跟谁谈，如果是科学家与硬件工程师或其他人相比，
push us towards wanting a smaller standard library because that's lower risk. Putting things into the standard library is higher risk. We have to be very certain that we've got them right. As for what I think belongs in the standard library, I think things that go into the standard library need to meet one of these three criterion. This is what I refer to as the clear need in my mantra of we standardize existing practice when there is a clear need. Yeah, I was going to ask about that because, yeah, clear need, depending on who you're talking to, if it's a scientist versus a hardware engineer versus something else,
他们的明确需求将完全不同。对，对。当我说明确需求时，我指的是这三件事之一。A，在接口中广泛使用。所以这是类似 std tuple 或 std vector 的东西，将其放在标准库中的原因是，如果你不把它放在标准库中，那么一堆不同的第三方库将提供它们自己的版本。并且这些东西往往会出现在接口中。因此，如果标准库，你知道，让我们以字符串为例，因为那是该领域经常令人痛苦的点之一。假设库 A 有自己的字符串类型，库 B 有自己的字符串类型，库 C 有自己的字符串类型。并且这些字符串类型之间都不可转换或互操作。而你，程序员，想使用所有这三个库。所以现在你不得不在你的程序中处理三种不同的字符串类型
like their clear needs are going to be completely different. Right, right. And when I say clear need, I mean one of these three things. A, wide use in interfaces. So this is something like std tuple or std vector, where the reason to have it in the standard library is that if you don't have it in the standard library, then a bunch of different third-party libraries will provide their own version. And these things tend to appear in interfaces. So if standard library, you know, let's use strings as an example, because that is one of the ones that's often a pain point in the field. Let's say that library A has its own string type and library B has its own string type and library C has its own string type. And none of those string types are convertible or interoperable between them. And you, the programmer, wants to use all three of those libraries. So now you've got to traffic in three different string types in your program
而且你可能不得不编写代码在它们之间进行转换。而且所有这些库，它们可能都有接收字符串的接口。所以它不仅仅是该库的实现细节。它是浮现在向你（用户）公开的接口中的东西。因此，在这种情况下，对于类似的事情，我们有强烈的动机把它放进标准库，以便它是标准词汇表的一部分。我们通常称这些东西为词汇类型。这样我们就可以有一种字符串类型，std string，并且所有这三个库都可以接受 std string 作为其接口的一部分。所以这是第一条，也就是当它是某种
and you may have to write code to convert between them. And all those libraries, they've probably got interfaces that take strings. So it's not just an implementation detail of the library. It's something that's surfaced in the interface that's exposed to you, the user. So in that case, for something like that, there is a strong motivation for us to put it in the standard library so that it's part of the standard vocabulary. We often call these things vocabulary types. So then we can have one string type, std string, and all three of those libraries can accept std strings as part of their interface. So that's bullet number one, which is when it's something that's
在接口中被广泛使用并且我们希望有一个标准版本的东西时。第二件事，第二个标准，是封装非可移植性的东西。比如 std file system、并发库、std atomics、IO streams，这些东西将在每个不同的平台、每个不同的操作系统、每个不同的嵌入式环境等中以不同的方式实现，在这些环境中，你作为程序员，可能不想自己编写这些。你可能希望提供你的平台的人、你平台的供应商、这方面的专家，
widely used in interfaces and we want to have one standard version of it. The second thing, the second criterion, is things that encapsulate non-portability. So things like std file system, the concurrency library, std atomics, IO streams, things that are going to be implemented in a different way for each different platform, in each different operating system, each different embedded environment, etc., where you, the programmer, probably don't want to be writing those yourself. You probably want the person who's providing your platform, who's the vendor of your platform, who's the expert on it,
为他们的平台提供一个合适的版本。这些东西属于标准库。然后最后一件事是那些并非真正纯粹的库设施，而是具有语言组件或需要语言支持的设施。例如，像类型特征或协程库的所有位。这些东西属于标准库，因为，好吧，它们是核心语言的一部分，或者它们与核心语言有联系，并且它们必须通过编译器和标准库之间的某些内部契约来实现。这不是你可以自己实现的东西。就是这样。这就是我的三个标准。它是被广泛使用的东西
to provide a suitable version for their platform. Those sorts of things belong in the standard library. And then the last thing is facilities that are not really truly purely library facilities, but that have a language component or that require language support. For example, things like type traits or all of the coroutines library bits. Those belong in the standard library because, well, they're part of the core language or they have ties to the core language and they have to be implemented through some internal contract between the compiler and the standard library. It's not something that you could implement on your own. And that's it. Those are my three criterion. It's things that are widely used
在接口中，封装非可移植性的东西，或者需要语言支持的东西。我相信只有至少勾选了其中一个要点的东西才属于标准库。我想我们可以通过以下方式结束本期节目或将其收尾，也许你不想挑剔，或者也许你愿意挑剔，但是管道中有哪些你认为你知道的、排定用于 C++ 23、26、29 的提案，它们显然是映射到这三者之一的例子？它们显然是映射到这三者之一的例子。是的。好的。那我就举几个例子。首先我们来谈谈封装非可移植性。我们应该说，仅仅因为我们提到了这些提案并不意味着它们保证能进去，但请继续。好的。所以 C++23 的主要重点之一一直是网络支持。网络，网络库类似于文件系统之类的事情，因为它封装了非可移植性。Windows 和 Unix 平台具有非常不同的网络 API。所以
in interfaces, things that encapsulate non-portability, or things that require language support. I believe that only things that check off at least one of those bullet points belong in the standard library. So I guess we can we can wrap this episode up or wind it down by maybe or maybe you don't want to pick pick on but are there proposals in the pipeline that you think you know that are slotted for C++ 23, 26, 29, that clearly are examples that map to one of those three? That are clearly examples that map to one of those three. Yeah. Okay. So I'll give you a few. So first let's talk about the encapsulating non-portability. And we should say, just because we're mentioning these proposals doesn't mean they're guaranteed to get in, but continue. Right. So one of the big focuses for C++23 has been networking support. Networking, networking library is something that would be very similar to something like file system in that it's an encapsulation of non-portability. Windows and Unix platforms have very different network APIs. And so it would
如果我们创建一个抽象，让用户可以在这两个平台上以可移植的方式使用它来编写相同的代码，并让其，你知道的，实现由微软的专家（他们知道微软的网络 API 如何工作）和在 GCC 上工作的专家（他们知道 Unix 套接字如何工作）提供，那对用户将非常有用。另一个封装的例子，这实际上是一个既封装了非可移植性又在接口中广泛使用的例子，就是 executors（执行器）。因此，executors 旨在成为围绕执行资源的抽象，比如线程池等。所以它们有点符合封装非可移植性的类别。executor 提案中的内容之一是这种静态线程池类型，它是一个具体的 executor
be very useful to users for us to create an abstraction that they could use on both platforms portably to write the same code and have it be, you know, have the implementation be provided by the experts at Microsoft who know how the Microsoft networking APIs work and the experts who work on GCC who know how Unix sockets work. Another example of encapsulating, this is one that's really an example of both encapsulating non-portability and wide use in interfaces would be executors. So executors are intended to be an abstraction around execution resources, things like thread pools, etc. So they sort of fit into the category of encapsulating non-portability. One of the things that's in the executor proposal is this static thread pool type, which is a concrete executor
类型。在不同的平台上，该静态线程池将以不同的方式实现。而且它可能比你想象的更加定制化。就像你可能认为的那样，嗯，在不同的 Unix 平台上只会有一种实现，然后在不同的 Windows 平台上有一种，但事实可能并非如此。想想嵌入式 Linux 平台（你可能希望那里的线程池是什么样子）与在 HPC 集群中运行的高性能服务器之间的差异。
type. On different platforms, that static thread pool is going to be implemented in different ways. And it might be even more customized than you think. Like you might think, well, there's just going to be one implementation on the different Unix platforms and then one on the different Windows platforms, but that might not be the case. Think about the difference between an embedded Linux platform, what you might want a thread pool to look like there, versus a high-performance server that's running in an HPC cluster.
但 executors 也是词汇类型，因为我们认为它们有点像并发算法的迭代器，它们将被传递到一堆不同的接口中。因此，在标准库中定义这种抽象的核心概念对我们来说非常有用，这样人们就可以去编写在他们自己的代码中使用该抽象的泛型算法。最后，让我们以反射库为例，它是一个需要语言 support 的东西。目前有很多工作正在进行，旨在将静态反射添加到 C++ 语言中。显然，这有一个非常庞大的编译器组件。
But executors are also vocabulary types because we think that they'll sort of be like the iterators of concurrent algorithms where there'll be something that's going to be passed in to a bunch of different interfaces. So it's very useful for us to define the core notion of what this abstraction is in the standard library so that people can go and write generic algorithms that use that abstraction in their own code. And then finally, let's use the reflection library as an example of something that will require language support. So there's a lot of work going on to add static reflection to the C++ language. And obviously that has a very large compiler component.
但在实际公开数据的编译器机制之上，你需要一种在你的程序中实际访问它的方法。这将通过库风格的 API 来实现。而且，你不仅需要用于获取该反射元数据的库 API，你还需要编译期编程设施来处理和操作该反射信息并使用它。所以我认为这是你无法独自完成的事情的一个很好的例子。你不能作为第三方库完全凭一己之力实现反射。它需要编译器支持。是的，这些都是很好的例子。是的。我以为你会向我索取不属于这些类别的例子
But on top of the compiler mechanisms that actually expose the data, you need a way to actually access it in your program. And that's going to be through a library style API. And also, you don't just need the library API for getting that reflection metadata. You also need the compile time programming facilities to work with and manipulate that reflection information and use it. So I think that's a really good example of something that you can't do on your own. You can't make reflection happen solely on your own as a third-party library. It requires compiler support. Yeah, those are great examples. Yeah. I thought you were going to ask me for examples of things
。而我原本打算说，我想我做不到。因为，当然，委员会中存在不同的信仰。归根结底，本周我们召开了 C++ 库演进委员会的会议，我们在会上讨论了设计准则。我们说的第一件事之一就是，你知道，我们不会有设计规则。这有点像《加勒比海盗》的那个模因，即它们不是规则，它们更像是指导方针。代码与其说是规则，不如说是你所谓的指导方针。
that don't fall into those categories. And I was going to say, I don't think I can do that. Because, of course, there are differing beliefs on the committee. And at the end of the day, we had a meeting this week of the C++ Library Evolution Committee where we were talking about design guidelines. And one of the first things that we said is, you know, we're not going to have design rules. It's sort of that Pirates of the Caribbean meme of they're not rules, they're more like guidelines. The code is more what you call guidelines than actual rules.
不属于这些类别。我本来想说，我想我做不到这一点。因为，当然，委员会内部存在不同的看法。归根结底，本周我们 C++ 库演进委员会开了一次会，讨论了设计指南。我们说的第一件事就是，你知道，我们不会制定设计规则。这有点像《加勒比海盗》里的那个梗：它们不是规则，更像是指南。这些代码与其说是实际规则，不如说是你所谓的指南。
There are really no hard and fast rules in the C++ standard library design. Just because I, the current chair, and a bunch of other people have a certain belief about what belongs in the standard library, A, doesn't mean that everybody agrees with us, and B, it doesn't mean that there aren't exceptions to that, to those rules, you know. If there is something that the committee agrees is important that doesn't really fall into my criterion, I'm not going to stand on the principle. At the end of the day, we have to be flexible and we don't want to let a set of criterion or a set of rules overly constrain us. But I do fundamentally believe that a smaller standard library
C++标准库的设计其实没有什么硬性且绝对的规则。仅仅因为我作为现任主席以及其他一些人对什么应该进入标准库持有某种信念，并不意味着A，所有人都同意我们的看法，B，并不意味着不存在这些规则的例外。你知道，如果委员会一致认为某项事物很重要，但它并不完全符合我的标准，我也不会固守原则。归根结底，我们必须保持灵活性，我们不想让一套标准或规则过度约束我们。但我从根本上相信，一个较小的标准库
is better for C++ than a bigger one and that what we really need is to make it easier to use third-party libraries in C++ and that that will alleviate a lot of the desire to have a wide, large standard library in C++. Yeah, I think for our listeners, regardless of whether they agree or disagree with your philosophy and the three things that define a clear need, I think it's useful just to keep in mind if you are trying to propose something and get it standardized in C++, keeping in mind that list of three things and potentially molding your proposal so that it more clearly satisfies one or more of those three things is not going to hurt. Right. So yeah. Yep. I certainly agree with that. And with that, yeah, we should probably call it. Yep. Sounds good. Thanks for listening and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对C++而言比一个庞大的标准库更好，我们真正需要的是让C++更容易使用第三方库，这将缓解很大一部分在C++中拥有一个庞大标准库的需求。是的，我认为对于我们的听众来说，无论他们是否同意你的哲学以及定义明确需求的这三件事，我认为记住这一点很有用：如果你正试图提出某项提案并使其在C++中标准化，那么记住那三条标准，并可能调整你的提案，使其更清晰地满足这三条标准中的一条或多条，是百利而无一害的。没错。所以，是的。是的，我当然同意这一点。那么，差不多就这样吧。好的，听起来不错。谢谢收听，祝您有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。